well lots of shiny a lot of things I
guess right there's there's a wide
variety of lists and I think
fundamentally people like lists and so
there are lists that would be outside
the Forbes brand and there are lists
that are inside the Forbes brain so
makes a good Forbes list is something
that's inside the Forbes brand but also
has a wide degree of interest so
certainly rich people you know are us
wealth list and our worldwide
billionaires list and an individual
country list to do quite well around the
world but then even getting into
specific types of things you know most
expensive houses most expensive city to
live in sometimes negative lists work
worst automobiles of all time was a big
list there for a while and sometimes we
will get a little bit of a little fun
with it and we'll do the highest-earning
cartoons or fictional characters I say
cartoons because I think Scrooge McDuck
is usually the number one listia that
list and then we will do our top earning
dead celebrities list which we usually
try to do around Halloween somehow seems
strangely appropriate
well you know they'll run the gambit we
try to be very very factual and how we
do it obviously when we get into the
more humorous and whimsical for example
fictional characters there will in fact
be a methodology behind it but that
methodology is one that you know sort of
has a but were they say in Paris the
calorie Caribbean it's kind of a loose
guideline but other than that there's
very very hard and fast rules and before
in fact for our celebrity list and our
rich lists we have a fairly large staff
working on those lists all year round
digging into individuals digging into
what they own what stock they have how
the companies they're invested with are
doing and then other times our list will
be pulled out of either public place
documents or census numbers or US
government numbers or some other third
party of some credible source who has
issued metrics in some way shape or form